the dream starts on the page the vision
takes shape in the directors imagination
the producer makes it happen
and the actors bring it to life the five
women we honor tonight have brilliantly
fulfilled that dream here are the
nominees for Best Actress in a leading
role Susan Sarandon in dead man walking
elisabeth shue in leaving Las Vegas
Sharon Stone in casino
Meryl Streep in The Bridges of Madison
County
Emma Thompson in Sense and Sensibility
and the Oscar goes to Susan Sarandon and
Deb Bandra
oh my thank you um members of the
Academy for including me in the fine
presence of these other great actors and
for giving me this opportunity to thank
people that are so dear to my heart for
making this happen
first of all sister Helen Prejean who's
here tonight for trusting us with your
with your with your life and bringing
your light in your love into all of our
lives Sam Cohen my dear friend Lynn
goldsmith Arlene Donovan he should be so
happy because this would not have
happened without you Oh a big thanks to
Martha luttrell and Nancy Selzer for
their support to the crew who worked so
hard and so well for so little to keep
me safe make me laugh and do their job I
thank you the crew the rest of the
ensemble especially Celia Witt ray Barry
R lee ermey Roberta Maxwell Louis Smith
all those mothers and fathers without
whose strong performances the film would
not have been as balanced and had as
much dignity as it did I thank you for
that
big thanks to Sean Penn Oh for your
for your intelligence and your courage
and your humor and your hairdo and it
was a great dance thank you so much to
my kids ever Jack Henry and Myles thanks
for being such good sports and who were
in the movie and did a great job and
finally to my partner in crime and all
things of the heart the writer the
producer the director the spirit Tim
Robbins
you kept us on track you fought so hard
thank God for your stubbornness thank
God for everything about you we would
not have had anything without you this
is yours as much as mine thank God we
live together may all of us find in our
hearts and in our homes and in our world
away to non-violently and violence and
heal thank you